Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two.
David P. This voicemail dives into a very
controversial issue of IQ education and financial
success.
Let's listen to how the caller frames it up.
Take a listen to this.
Speaker 2: Hey, David, please, please, please
perform an analysis on this anomaly.
If more education correlates with higher income
level, education correlates with better intelligence.
Why did 54 percent of the voters earning more
than 100k vote for Trump?
OK, explain this, and I will forever address
you as sir, and I will forgive you for referring
to the University of Pennsylvania as stupid.
All right.
Take care of my friend.
Speaker 1: Oh, my God.
I didn't know you weren't supposed to say
you, Penn, no less.
So there's a couple of things going on.
The link between IQ and income is only correlated
in a certain part of the band.
And what I mean by that is if you have a really
low IQ to the point at which it would identify
a cognitive issue that has a very negative
impact on earning potential.
But what you see is that once you get if I'm
trying to remember, this is this is an Nassim
Taleb has written about this.
Once you get just a little bit above average
IQ, you don't see much of an earnings premium
as IQ goes up higher and higher.
And so I think that maybe the premises here
aren't quite right.
And in particular, if you set the bar at one
hundred thousand dollars, there are tons of
people without college degrees who earn one
hundred thousand dollars.
There are lots of trades in which you can
earn one hundred thousand dollars.
So I think that, you know, I'm glad to address
the issue of income and voting tendencies.
And you have to remember that the one reason
that people with higher incomes, regardless
of education level and regardless of intelligence,
might lean Republican, and this is a historical
reality, is because as someone with a higher
income, they may see that Republicans will
make them pay less in taxes.
And so I think that, you know, you're sort
of on to something interesting and exploring,
but some of the premises there are not quite
right on the bonus show today.
We will talk about Caitlyn Jenner's run for
California governor running as a Republican.
What will the trans community think of a Republican
trans candidate?
What will California Republicans think of
a trans candidate?
A lot of interesting dynamics there.
We will also talk about Joe Biden recognizing
the Armenian genocide as a genocide, which
Armenians liked and the Turkish folks did
not.
And there is a lot of controversy around this.
We will also talk about Joe Biden wanting
to make community college free, but progressives
aren't satisfied with that.
What more might progressives be able to get
from Joe Biden on that?
Where are we on debt cancelation?
A lot to talk about with Joe Biden and education.
Those stories and more on today's bonus show
to get instant access to the bonus show.
It's very simple.
You go to join Pakman Dotcom and you sign
up.
That's it.
And I will see you on the bonus show in mere
moments.